From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Amidst the confusion and chaos of the COVID-19 pandemic, many of us have sought out a long-trusted lifeline. The local newspaper. Reporters venturing out to hospitals, to remote areas, to nursing homes, they tell us what's happening in the world in our country and in our own communities. They let us track the spread of disease, the
这里是NPR的《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在新冠疫情的混乱与迷茫中，我们许多人都寻找了一条长期信赖的生命线：当地报纸。记者们冒险前往医院、偏远地区和养老院，向我们讲述这个世界、我们的国家以及我们自己的社区正在发生的事情。他们让我们得以追踪病毒的传播、
availability of ICU beds, the well-being of our neighbors. It should come as no surprise that in the past couple of months, print an online local newspaper readership has soared. Yet at this time, when the value of local journalism is most evident, as readers are inhaling article after article, newspapers are not thriving. They are collapsing. Well, it is a difficult day for journalism in Cleveland. Today, the plain dealer newsroom went from 38 employees down to 16. Well, North Dakota's two largest newspapers
重症监护室床位的紧张程度，以及邻居们的幸福安康。毫无疑问，在过去的几个月里，印刷版和在线地方报纸的读者数量急剧飙升。然而，正当地方新闻的价值最明显、读者一篇接一篇地阅读文章之际，报纸并没有蓬勃发展，它们正在崩溃。对克利夫兰的新闻界来说，这是艰难的一天。今天，《诚实人报》的编辑部员工从38人锐减到了16人。北达科他州的两大报纸
are taking steps to trim costs amid the coronavirus outbreak. COVID-19 vaporized the papers advertising. Revenue is down more than 30%. The 98 of the company's 375 employees have inferlode or had their hours cut back. The problem is only going to grow. Advertising revenue, which newspapers rely on, is vanishing as business is shutter and people practice social distancing. For many publications, COVID-19 might be the final nail in the coffin.
正在采取措施在冠状病毒爆发期间削减成本。新冠疫情蒸发了报纸的广告收入，收入下降了超过30%。公司375名员工中有98人被强制休假或被削减了工作时间。问题只会越来越严重。报纸赖以生存的广告收入随着企业关门和人们实行社交距离而消失。对于许多出版物来说，新冠疫情可能是棺材板上的最后一颗钉子。
For decades, the financial health of many newspapers has been precarious, in good economic times, and bad. If you talk to people who don't subscribe to their local paper, you can see why the industry is in dire straits. Here are some Denver residents we spoke with. I've never subscribed to a local publication. I usually just get the free ones like Westwood, the free one that comes out in the little red bins
几十年来，无论经济形势好坏，许多报纸的财务健康状况一直岌岌可危。如果你和那些不订购当地报纸的人谈谈，你就会明白为什么这个行业陷入了绝境。以下是我们采访的一些丹佛居民。我从未订购过当地的出版物。我通常只看免费的，比如韦斯特伍德，那种散落在丹佛各地小红箱子里的免费报纸。喜欢优惠券。我买报纸就是为了优惠券。我的意思是脸书上什么都有，所以。
all over Denver. Love the coupons. What I wanted the paper for is the coupons. And I mean Facebook has everything, so. Their logic and that of millions of Americans is that there are lots of options to pay little or nothing to read the news. There are blogs, there's Facebook, there's Twitter. Why subscribe if you don't have time to read the paper? If you think the paper is biased, if you want to save money.
他们的逻辑以及数百万美国人的逻辑是，有很多选择可以花很少甚至不花钱来阅读新闻。有博客，有脸书，有推特。既然没时间读报、觉得报纸有偏见、或者想省钱，为什么还要订阅呢？
All of this makes rational sense. Except, it doesn't. That's because newspapers are not like most things we buy. If we decide not to buy an espresso machine, we save money. But if we decide not to pay for a police department, we might save money in the short run, but end up paying much more in the long run. Most of us treat newspapers like consumer products,
这一切在理性上都讲得通。除了，它其实讲不通。那是因为报纸不像我们购买的大多数东西。如果我们决定不买浓缩咖啡机，我们省了钱。但如果我们决定不为警察局出资，我们可能在短期内省了钱，但从长远来看最终会付出更多。我们大多数人都把报纸当作消费品，
but new research suggests they might be more like police departments. This week on Hidden Brain, we bring back an episode from 2018 that's acutely relevant right now. We ask who bears the cost when nobody wants to pay. In the winter of 2009, a few denware-based reporters headed to a region of mountains and canyons called the Roan Plateau. Just a few years earlier, it was the site of an oil and gas boom. But that boom had turned into a bust. So, we were going up the room plateau where many fewer workers were employed and looking at how people were struggling to try to keep things going and make ends meet.
但新的研究表明，它们可能更像是警察局。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们重播2018年的一期节目，这期节目与当下高度相关。我们探讨当没有人愿意付费时，成本由谁来承担。2009年冬天，几名常驻丹佛的记者前往一个名为罗恩高原的山脉和峡谷地区。就在几年前，这里还是石油和天然气繁荣的工地。但这种繁荣已经变成了萧条。因此，我们前往罗恩高原，那里就业的工人少了很多，看看人们是如何挣扎着维持生计的。
Laura Frank was an investigative reporter for the Rocky Mountain News. We were riding up with some of the oil and gas workers trying to get up the plateau. It had rained and so the dirt road going up the plateau had turned really into kind of a muddy mess. And here we are sliding in this pickup truck, trying to get up the plateau, when suddenly we see these semi-trucks coming down the same road and not sure what kind of control they were under. And I'm thinking, why am I risking my life for a newspaper that's about to close? A newspaper that was about to close. Laura was worried about the rocky. Several weeks earlier, a
劳拉·弗兰克是《落基山新闻报》的调查记者。我们和一些油气工人一起坐车试图上高原。天一直在下雨，所以上高原的土路实际上已经变成了一片泥泞的烂摊子。我们坐着这辆皮卡车打滑，试图爬上高原，突然我们看到这些半挂卡车沿着同一条路开下来，不确定它们处于什么控制状态。我在想，我为什么要为一个即将倒闭的报纸冒着生命危险？一份即将倒闭的报纸。劳拉对《落基山报》感到担忧。几周前，一个
balding man in a suit had stood in the middle of her newsroom. Reporters and editors clustered around in a circle. Many had their arms crossed. Some scribbled in notebooks. This is a newsroom, so I doubt I actually need to give you the headline. It must have been probably already known, but we're going to announce just in the next few minutes that we're going to put the Rocky Mountain news up for sale. Laura had listened to the announcement with dismay. The newspaper was going to either be sold in the next 30 days or it would be closed. And if you remember what was happening in December of 2008, we knew we were on the verge either of a great recession or the next great depression. So I was pretty sure that they probably weren't going to sell the newspaper over the holidays
秃顶、穿着西装的男人站在她新闻部的中央。记者和编辑们围成一个圈。许多人抱着双臂。一些人在笔记本上涂鸦。这是一个新闻部，所以我怀疑我其实不需要给你们看标题。这可能大家已经知道了，但我们将在接下来的几分钟内宣布，我们要将《落基山新闻报》挂牌出售。劳拉带着沮丧的心情听取了这一宣布。这家报纸要么在未来30天内售出，要么就会关门。如果你还记得2008年12月发生的事情，我们知道我们正处于大萧条或下一次大衰退的边缘。所以我非常确凿地认为，他们可能不会在假期里在30天内卖掉这份报纸，当时没有人知道经济前景究竟会怎样。
in 30 days when no one knew what the economic outlook was really going to be. Days after her reporting trip to the Rome Plateau, Laura got word about her fate at the Rocky. The corporate managers had flown in and you know you're in a big and sophisticated newsroom. We knew they had landed, people had sources at the airport, we knew they were there and we pretty much knew what they were going to say. The same balding man in a suit gathered journalists around him. Tomorrow will be the final edition of the Rocky Mountain Dews. Certainly not good news for any of you and certainly not good news for Denver. Just want to make sure and say it. Certainly nothing you did, you all did everything right.
在她去罗恩高原报道几天后，劳拉得到了她在《落基山报》命运的消息。公司高管乘飞机赶来，你知道你在一个大型且成熟的新闻部。我们知道他们着陆了，人们在机场有消息来源，我们知道他们在那里，我们基本上也知道他们要说什么。同一个秃顶穿西装的男人把记者们聚集在周围。明天将是《落基山新闻报》的最后一版。对你们任何人来说这当然都不是好消息，对丹佛来说也绝对不是好消息。我只想确保并说出来。绝对不是你们做了什么，你们所有人都做对了。
But while you were out doing your part, the business model and the economy changed, and the Rocky became a victim of that. Denver can't support two newspapers any longer, especially two morning full distribution, general interest newspapers, it just can't happen. It was very hard to leave that night. I remember sitting at my desk for a very long time, just sitting there and not, you know, I was finished. There was nothing more I could do, but I didn't want to walk out of there.
但当你们在外履行职责时，商业模式和经济发生了变化，而《落基山报》成为了牺牲品。丹佛再也无法支撑两家报纸了，尤其是两家早间全发行、大众兴趣的报纸，这是不可能发生的。那天晚上离开很难。我记得我在办公桌前坐了很长很长时间，只是坐在那里，没有，你知道的，我结束了。我无能为力，但我不想从那里走出去。
The story about the oil and gas past that Laura had spent weeks working on, it was scheduled to run that Saturday. The rocky closed one day earlier, on Friday. When Laura left the rocky newsroom for the last time, she was concerned about her own future, but she was even was concerned about her own future, but she was even more concerned about the work she had left undone. I had all of these stacks of documents on my desk at the Rocky Mountain News, each representing some issue that I thought needed investigating.
劳拉花了数周时间进行报道的关于油气过去的报道，原计划在那个星期六刊登。《落基山报》提前一天在周五关闭了。当劳拉最后一次离开《落基山新闻报》的新闻部时，她关心自己的未来，但她甚至更关心她自己未来的命运，但她更关心的是她留下来未完成的工作。我在《落基山新闻报》的办公桌上有成堆的文件，每一叠都代表着我认为需要调查的问题。
One of those issues was electronics waste or e-waste. The very week that the Rocky Mountain News closed that last week of February in 2009, federal agents had raided an electronics recycler. That raid came after a dramatic investigation by 60 minutes. Tonight we're going to take you to one of the most toxic places on Earth, a place that government officials and gangsters don't want you to see. The 60-minute investigation alleged this company had sent e-waste to China where people were dipping parts and acid and burning them over open flames to get little bits of gold and
其中一个问题是电子垃圾。就在《落基山新闻报》关闭的那周——2009年2月最后一周，联邦特工突击搜查了一家电子产品回收商。这次突击搜查是在《60分钟》节目进行了一项戏剧性的调查之后进行的。今晚我们将带你前往地球上最毒的地方之一，一个政府官员和匪徒不想让你看到的地方。《60分钟》的调查称，这家公司将电子垃圾运往中国，那里的人们将零件浸泡在酸液中并在明火上燃烧，以获取少量的金和
other metals. And they were exposing the village to dangerous levels of lead. In fact, 70% of the kids in that village had dangerous levels of lead in their blood. So here you had an ongoing federal investigation into the role of Colorado company allegedly played in endangering kids in a foreign nation. And my newspaper was shutting down.
其他金属。他们将这个村庄暴露在危险水平的铅污染中。事实上，那个村子里70%的孩子的血液中铅含量达到危险水平。因此，当时你面对的是一项正在进行的联邦调查，涉及一家科罗拉多州公司据称在危及外国儿童方面所起的作用。而我的报纸却要倒闭了。
We couldn't investigate, but the worst thing was no other local media had the capacity to investigate it either. What happens when a newspaper isn't around to dig into stories of corruption and malfeasance? Like millions of people around the country, denver's residents decided not to subscribe to their local newspaper for what seemed like perfectly good reasons. They were busy, the news was depressing, the paper was expensive, but these rational choices as consumers turned out to have serious consequences for them as taxpayers and citizens. Stay with us. There's a graph that I saw years ago that stood out to me so much that I now have it pinned to the wall in my office.
我们无法进行调查，但最糟糕的是，其他本地媒体也没有能力进行调查。当没有报纸去挖掘腐败和渎职的故事时会发生什么？就像全国数百万的人一样，丹佛的居民出于看似充分的理由决定不订阅当地报纸。他们很忙，新闻令人沮丧，报纸很贵，但这些作为消费者的理性选择，结果却给他们作为纳税人和公民带来了严重的后果。请留下来。多年前我看到过一张图表，它对我的触动如此之深，以至于我把它别在了办公室的墙上。
It has a red line and a blue line. The red represents newspaper advertising revenue. The blue shows the number of newspaper reporters in the country. From 1980 to the early 2000s, ad revenue, the red line, rose and rose and rose. It peaked in the early 2000s. Then there was a cliff. As people cancelled subscriptions and advertising revenue plummeted, so did the number of reporters, the blue line. Between 2006 and 2014, some 20,000 newspaper journalists lost their jobs. Now you can say, this is how capitalism works. Industry shrink, others grow. But is it possible that newspapers don't fit neatly into this economic model?
它有一条红线和一条蓝线。红色代表报纸广告收入。蓝色显示该国报纸记者的数量。从1980年到2000年代初，广告收入即红线不断上升。它在2000年代初达到顶峰。然后出现了一个悬崖。随着人们取消订阅和广告收入暴跌，记者人数（蓝线）也随之下降。2006年至2014年间，大约2万名报纸记者失去了工作。现在你可以说，这就是资本主义的运作方式。一些行业萎缩，另一些行业增长。但有没有可能报纸并不完全符合这种经济模式？
That they have a different kind of effect on their communities. Finance professors Paul Gao, Dermot Murphy and Chang Lee were thinking about the effect of newspaper shutting down when they spotted something on YouTube. We were watching this segment from this TV show called last week tonight with John Oliver about the state of the local newspaper in the United States. This is Dermot Murphy. John Oliver was explaining what Americans lose when newspapers disappear. Watch how often TV news ends up citing print sources.
它们对社区有着不同类型的影响。金融学教授保罗·高、德莫特·墨菲和张力在YouTube上发现了一些东西时，他们正在思考报纸倒闭的影响。我们正在观看这个名为约翰·奥利弗上周今夜秀的电视节目片段，关于美国地方报纸的现状。这是德莫特·墨菲。约翰·奥利弗在解释美国人在报纸消失时失去了什么。看看电视新闻最终引用印刷来源的频率有多高。
According to the Chicago Tribune? According to the Detroit Free Press. According to the San Francisco Chronicle. According to the Times Picky Un. The Boston Globe Free Press. According to the San Francisco Chronicle. According to the Timespicking Un. The Boston Globe. The Orlando Sentinel. The Philadelphia Inquiry. The Pittsburgh Tribune Review.
根据《芝加哥论坛报》？根据《底特律自由报》。根据《旧金山纪事报》。根据《皮尤时报》。《波士顿环球报》《自由报》。根据《旧金山纪事报》。根据《皮尤时报》。《波士顿环球报》。《奥兰多哨兵报》。《费城问询报》。《匹兹堡论坛评论报》。
The Detroit News. And the Houston Chronicle reports. The Los Angeles Times reports. The Oklahoma reports. The Hartford Current reports. The Salt Lake Tribune reports. It's pretty obvious. Without newspapers around to sight, TV news would just be
《底特律新闻报》。以及《休斯顿纪事报》的报道。《洛杉矶时报》报道。《俄克拉荷马报》报道。《哈特福德信使报》报道。《盐湖城论坛报》报道。这显而易见。如果没有报纸可以引用，电视新闻就只会是
Wolf Blitzer endlessly batting a ball of yarn around. So, as finance professors, we thought it would be important to look at the effective newspaper closures on local communities from the finance angle. The researchers had a hunch that the loss of newspaper jobs could affect municipal finance. Now, that sounds wonky, but let me explain why this is actually a big deal. Just as you borrow money from a bank to buy a house, towns and cities borrow money to build police stations, senior centers, and bridges. Taxpayers pay off these loans over time, just as homeowners pay off their mortgages.
沃尔夫·布利策无休止地拍打着一团纱线。因此，作为金融教授，我们认为从金融角度来看，研究报纸倒闭对当地社区的影响非常重要。研究人员有一种直觉，即报纸工作的丧失可能会影响市政财政。现在，这听觉上可能有点古怪，但让我解释一下为什么这其实是一件大事。就像你从银行借钱买房一样，城镇借钱建造警察局、老年人中心和桥梁。纳税人随着时间推移还清这些贷款，就像房主还清抵押贷款一样。
Durma thought they might be a relationship between the cost of loans to cities and towns and disappearing newspapers. The researchers tallied every time a newspaper shut down between 1996 and 2015. They found 200 counties across the United States where there was a decline in the number of newspapers. They compared these counties to similar counties in the same state when newspapers were thriving. Once we had this information collected, we were able to see basically how government borrowing
德莫特认为，城市和城镇的贷款成本与不断消失的报纸之间可能存在某种关系。研究人员统计了1996年至2015年间报纸倒闭的每一次事件。他们发现在全美范围内有200个县的报纸数量出现下降。他们将这些县与报纸繁荣时期同一州内类似的县进行了比较。一旦我们收集了这些信息，我们基本上就能看到在报纸倒闭后，政府借款
costs increase in the longer run after a newspaper closure. Dermot and his colleagues found that when a newspaper closed, the cost of loans in its county went up. This happened all over the country, including in Denver, home of the now closed Rocky Mountain News. Dermott says, one deceptively tiny number tells a significant story. In the long run, after a newspaper closes,
成本在长期内是如何增加的。德莫特和他的同事发现，当一家报纸倒闭时，其所在县的贷款成本就会上升。这种情况在全国各地都有发生，包括丹佛，这里是现在已经倒闭的《落基山新闻报》的所在地。德莫特说，一个看似微不足道的数字讲述了一个重大的故事。从长远来看，在报纸倒闭后，
the borrowing cost for governments increases by about 0.1%. Now, the interest rate on a loan increasing from say 3% to 3.1% may not sound like much. But here's how it adds up. On average, a loan for $65 million in our sample. If the cost of a loan goes up by 0.1%,
政府的借款成本大约增加了0.1%。现在，贷款利率从比如3%上升到3.1%听起来可能不算什么。但它是这样累积起来的。在我们样本中，平均一笔6500万美元的贷款。如果贷款成本上升0.1%，
that's about $65,000 more that taxpayers have to pay. $65,000 more every year. If the life of a loan is 10 years, that's about $650,000. And that's just for one loan. Cities and towns often have many loans like this. If a city has five projects, that's more than $3 million. If it has 50 projects, it's more than $30 million. That it has 50 projects, it's more than 30 million dollars. That does add up to real costs for the taxpayer. The effect showed up even after the researchers controlled for population growth and differences in local economies. It affected areas that were booming and areas that were shrinking.
那大约是纳税人必须多支付65,000美元。每年多付65,000美元。如果贷款期限是10年，那就是大约650,000美元。而这只是一笔贷款。城市和城镇通常有很多这样的贷款。如果一个城市有五个项目，那就是超过300万美元。如果有50个项目，那就是超过3000万美元。如果有50个项目，那就是超过3000万美元。这确实给纳税人带来了实际成本。即使在研究人员控制了人口增长和地方经济差异之后，这种影响依然显现。它影响了经济繁荣的地区和正在萎缩的地区。
Dermot things that borrowing costs go up because something important disappears when newspapers close. The Watchdog channel. The Watchdog role that journalists play in holding public officials and powerful corporations accountable. When a newspaper closes or slashes its reporting staff, there's no one to play that role anymore. It's like getting rid of the police officers who patrol neighborhoods. Elected officials appear to know this. With the Denver Post announced cuts in 2018, this report popped up in the news. Another lawmakers joked about the cuts saying, hey, that means we can do whatever we want.
德莫特认为借款成本上升是因为当报纸倒闭时，一些重要的东西消失了：看门狗渠道。记者在追究公职人员和权贵责任方面发挥的看门狗作用。当报纸倒闭或大幅削减记者队伍时，就不再有人扮演这个角色了。这就像解雇了在社区巡逻的警察。民选官员似乎意识到了这一点。随着《丹佛邮报》在2018年宣布裁员，新闻界出现了这样一篇报道。另一位议员开玩笑说裁员，说，嘿，这意味着我们可以为所欲为。
Because fewer of the newspapers resources may go to the watchdog role of covering lawmakers at the Capitol. Dermot thinks the absence of watchdogs affects loan prices because banks realize their loans to local governments are now a little more risky. They know that some government officials will now be a little less honest, a little less careful. Lenders are a little more nervous about lending to such a government, and so when a lender is more nervous about lending to an inefficient government. And so when a lender is more nervous about lending to an inefficient government, then they're going to have to ask for a higher interest rate
因为报纸的资源可能较少用于在国会大厦报道议员的看门狗角色。德莫特认为，看门狗的缺席会影响贷款价格，因为银行意识到他们对地方政府的贷款现在风险更大一些。他们知道有些政府官员现在会变得不那么诚实、不那么谨慎。贷款人对向这样的政府放贷感到更加紧张，因此，当贷款人对向效率低下的政府放贷感到更加紧张时，他们就会要求更高的利率
on the money they're lending to compensate for that risk. John Oliver had a similar theory, but he put it a little differently. Not having reporters at government meetings is like a teacher leaving her room of seventh graders to supervise themselves. Best case scenario, Brittany gets gum in her hair. Worst case scenario, you no longer have a school!
他们借出的资金以弥补这种风险。约翰·奥利弗也有类似的理论，但他表达的方式略有不同。政府会议上没有记者就像老师离开七年级学生的教室让他们自己管理。最好的情况是，布兰妮的头发里粘了口香糖。最坏的情况是，你不再有学校了！
I-I look... You might be thinking here, okay, a lot of newspapers have closed, but there are now so many online publications. But these outlets do not appear to be an adequate replacement for a strong local newspaper. They are like having a community neighborhood watch. It's a wonderful compliment to a police department, but it's not a replacement for a police department.
我，我看……你可能会在这里想，好吧，很多报纸已经倒闭了，但现在有这么多的网络出版物。但这些媒体似乎并不能充分替代一份强大得力的地方报纸。它们就像拥有一个社区邻里守望组织。这是对警察局的一个绝妙补充，但它不能替代警察局。
If the internet is filling in the gap left to buy local newspaper closures, then we wouldn't see borrowing costs to go up like they are. We could even see them go down. At the state and local level, it's America's regional newspapers that are collapsing, they're imploding faster. That means David Simon used to be a reporter at the Baltimore Sun. He also created the TV series The Wire. About a decade ago, he made a diet prediction as newspaper after newspaper, laid off reporters.
如果互联网正在填补地方报纸倒闭留下的空白，那么我们不会看到借款成本像现在这样上升。我们甚至可能会看到它们下降。在州和地方一级，美国的区域性报纸正在崩溃，它们正在以更快的速度内爆。这意味着大卫·西蒙曾是《巴尔的摩太阳报》的一名记者。他还创作了电视剧《火线》。大约十年前，随着一家又一家报纸解雇记者，他做出了一个严峻的预测。
He testified before the US Senate and said that online publications were not going to cover goings on at City Hall and in state government. That means that all of a sudden there's nobody covering the cop shop, nobody covering the zoning board. The day I run into a Huffington Post reporter at a Baltimore zoning board hearing is the day that I will be confident that we've actually reached some sort of equilibrium. The next 10 or 15 years in this country are going to be a halcyon error for state and local political corruption.
他在美国参议院作证时表示，网络出版物不会报道市政厅和州政府的动态。这意味着突然之间没有人报道警局，没有人报道分区委员会。我有一天在巴尔的摩分区委员会听证会上遇到《赫芬顿邮报》记者的那一天，就是我确信我们实际上已经达到某种平衡的那一天。这个国家接下来的10到15年将是州和地方政治腐败的黄金时代。
It is going to be one of the great times to be a corrupt politician. Legislators laughed, but David Simon was serious. He predicted that closing newspapers would lead to more corruption. We can see hints of this in Denver. While we can't know what would have happened if the Rocky was still around, some stories of corruption and wrongdoing might have surfaced earlier if there were reporters to keep an eye on things. Roger's believes she was fired for being a whistleblower, helping her friend Michelle
这将是成为一名腐败政客的绝佳时机之一。议员们笑了，但大卫·西蒙是认真的。他预测关闭报纸会导致更多腐败。我们可以在丹佛看到这方面的迹象。虽然我们无法知道如果《落基山报》还在的话会发生什么，但如果有记者盯着事情，一些关于腐败和不当行为的故事可能会更早浮出水面。罗杰斯相信她因担任吹哨人而被解雇，她曾帮助她的朋友米歇尔
Edwardson, an animal control officer, write a complaint about then-chief of police, John Patterson. The law... We uncovered the DHS case worker, Rochana Madera, who was assigned to the case, never met with the family to make sure the baby was safe. And then she lied about it. 60 days later, Natalie was dead. Remember, these are the stories that did get out eventually.
爱德华森（一名动物管制官）撰写了针对时任警察局长约翰·帕特森的投诉。法律……我们发现被指派处理此案的儿童及家庭服务局（DHS）案卷工作者罗查娜·马德拉从未与该家人会面以确保婴儿的安全。然后她对此撒了谎。60天后，娜塔莉死了。记住，这些是最终确实被报道出来的故事。
We don't know what stories didn't make it out. While Dermott study looked at the financial effects of newspaper closures, you can imagine all kinds of other things that are affected when a newspaper closes. Public health, the environment, political engagement. It's this last area that Stanford economist Matthew Jensko has studied. He has examined how newspapers, prior to the advent of radio and TV, affected voter turnout. We find that there are large positive effects of newspaper entry on turnout.
我们不知道有哪些故事未能公之于众。虽然德莫特的研究着眼于报纸倒闭的财务影响，但你可以想象当报纸倒闭时，所有其他类型的事情都会受到影响：公共卫生、环境、政治参与。这是斯坦福大学经济学家马修·延斯科研究的最后一个领域。他考察了在广播和电视出现之前，报纸如何影响投票率。我们发现报纸的介入对投票率有很大的积极影响。
So if you look at places where a newspaper entered, turnout increases in the following election. If you look at a place where a newspaper exited, turnout falls in the following election. Matthew and his co-authors wanted to see if the results changed, once radio and TV entered the picture. The pattern is kind of interesting. I think what you see is that the role of newspapers
因此，如果你看看有报纸进驻的地方，在随后的选举中投票率会上升。如果你看看报纸退出V的地方，在随后的选举中投票率会下降。马修和他的合著者想要看看一旦广播和电视进入人们的视野，结果是否会改变。这种模式有点意思。我认为你看到的是，报纸的角色
in driving presidential election turnout gets smaller, as you might expect, given that now you no longer have to depend on newspapers. There are lots of other sources. Whereas the role of newspapers in driving congressional election turnout, local election turnout, or state level, turnout remains large throughout that period.
在推动总统选举投票率方面变得越来越小，正如你所预料的那样，鉴于现在你不再必须依赖报纸。还有很多其他的来源。而报纸在推动国会选举投票率、地方选举投票率或州一级投票率方面的作用在整个时期内仍然很大。
The reason? If you want to learn about the presidential election, you won't have trouble finding information on cable TV. But those national sources are not going to help you learn what's happening in your state, or county, or city. If you're trying to learn about the local congressional race in a particular district in Kansas, you can't learn anything about that from watching CNN. You can't learn anything about that from watching Fox News. And so the local newspaper in that part of Kansas
原因在于：如果你想了解总统选举，你在有线电视上找信息不会有困难。但那些国家级的消息来源并不能帮助你了解你的州、县或城市正在发生的事情。如果你试图了解堪萨斯州特定选区的当地国会竞选，你无法从观看CNN中了解到这一点。你无法从观看福克斯新闻中了解到这一点。因此，堪萨斯州那一部分的当地报纸
is likely to be reporting a bunch of information about those races that is not reported almost anywhere else. Matthew says local papers, they remain incredibly important and unique in many, many places in terms of coverage of local politics and local elections. It is local papers that have been decimated over the past two decades, and turnout in local elections looks no better. Portland State University found that in 10 of America's 30 largest cities, few are then 15% of voters turned out to vote for mayor. Let me repeat that. Few are then 15%. That makes turnout in the 2016 presidential election, 61% of eligible voters, seems
可能会报道一堆关于这些竞选的信息，而这些信息在其他地方几乎没有被报道。马修说，在地方政治和地方选举的报道方面，当地报纸在许多很多地方仍然非常重要和独特。正是地方报纸在过去二十年中遭到严重摧毁，地方选举的投票率也没有变得更好。波特兰州立大学发现，在美国30个最大城市中的10个城市中，投票选举市长的选民不到15%。让我重复一遍。不到15%。这使得2016年总统选举的投票率（占合格选民的61%）看起来
sky high. For a variety of reasons, some of which we might not understand, newspapers appear to be vital to the civic and financial health of their cities, just like public schools or libraries or fire departments. But unlike those other services, newspapers are also private entities that must succeed financially in order to survive. In some parts of the world, taxpayers finance public interest journalism in the same way they pay for national defense, highways, and police. But Laura Frank, the former investigative reporter at the Rocky, says it's a bad idea for
高耸入云。出于各种原因，其中有些我们可能无法理解，报纸似乎对城市的公民和财务健康至关重要，就像公立学校、图书馆或消防部门一样。但与那些其他服务不同的是，报纸也是私营实体，为了生存必须在财务上取得成功。在世界某些地方，纳税人资助公共利益新闻的方式与他们支付国防、高速公路和警察费用的方式相同。但《洛矶山新闻》的前调查记者劳拉·弗兰克表示，让...
newspapers to get money from the government. If a big part of the watchdog role that the Fourth of State has is making sure that different levels of government are operating in a healthy and good way, we can't be dependent on those same levels of government to fund what we're doing. Some newspapers are looking to individuals with deep pockets. Wealthy entrepreneurs have bought newspapers like The Washington Post and The Los Angeles Times. Each is seeing a sort of renaissance. They've hired dozens of journalists. There's also been growth in public radio. Many local stations are expanding coverage.
报纸从政府获取资金是个糟糕的主意。如果第四权力的监督角色很大一部分是确保不同级别的政府以健康和良好的方式运作，我们就不能依赖这些相同的政府级别来资助我们正在做的事情。一些报纸正在寻找财大气粗的个人。富有的企业家收购了《华盛顿 Post》和《洛杉矶时报》等报纸。每一家都在经历某种复兴。他们雇用了数十名记者。公共广播也有所增长。许多当地电台正在扩大报道范围。
And then there are nonprofits. After the Rocky shutdown, Laura started her own journalism outlet. I wound up actually being given a fellowship at the University of Colorado. Ironically, the Scripps Fellowship, named for the same family that owned the Rocky. She used the script's money to create an organization called I News. And the I stood for Investigative. And the idea was that we would do investigative stories and share them with other newsrooms. And that's what we did.
然后是非营利组织。在《洛矶山新闻》倒闭后，劳拉创办了自己的新闻机构。我最后实际上在科罗拉多大学获得了研究奖学金。讽刺的是，斯克里pps奖学金是以拥有《洛矶山新闻》的同一家族命名的。她用斯克里pps的资金创建了一个名为 I News 的组织。而 I 代表调查。其理念是我们将制作调查报道并与其它新闻室分享。这就是我们所做的。
Remember the story about E-Waste? The Laura never got to finish when she was at the Rocky? That was the first story. I put a reporter on the story who spoke Mandarin and using a couple of different databases, we were able to track a shipment of E-Waste from Colorado to Hong Kong, and our reporter was then able to confirm that this e-waste had been illegally exported. And that would have been an important story if we had stopped right there to say, you know, despite an ongoing federal investigation, illegal e-waste is still being exported to foreign nations. But we didn't stop there. We found that some of the same kinds of dangerous practices
还记得关于电子垃圾的故事吗？劳拉在《洛矶山新闻》时一直没能完成的故事？那是第一个故事。我指派了一名会说普通话的记者来报道这个故事，利用几个不同的数据库，我们得以追踪一批从科罗拉多州运往香港的电子垃圾，我们的记者随后能够确认这批电子垃圾被非法出口。如果我们就在那里停下来，说，你知道的，尽管联邦调查仍在进行，非法的电子垃圾仍然在出口到外国，那也将是一个重要的故事。但我们并没有止步于此。我们发现，某些同样危险的做法
that were happening in China and Hong Kong, like dipping parts and acid and burning them over open flames, it was happening right here in Colorado, on a much smaller scale, but completely under the radar of state regulators. They had no idea it was happening. And so that would have been an important part of the story, They had no idea it was happening. And so that would have been an important part of the story,
在中国和香港发生的事情，比如把零件浸泡在酸里并在明火上焚烧，就在科罗拉多州这里发生了，规模要小得多，但完全在州监管机构的雷达之外。他们根本不知道这件事正在发生。所以这将是故事的重要部分，他们根本不知道这件事正在发生。所以这将是故事的重要部分，
but we didn't stop there either. We found that most of Colorado's used electronic waste was actually winding up in local dumps, instead of being recycled. And again, I feel like one of those commercials, but that's not all. We didn't stop there. We found much of the e-waste that was being illegally exported, locally dumped, or dipped
但我们也没有止步于此。我们发现科罗拉多州大部分用过的电子垃圾实际上最终都进了当地的垃圾场，而不是被回收利用。再次，我觉得自己像是在拍商业广告，但还不止于此。我们没有停下来。我们发现很多被非法出口、本地倾倒或浸泡的电子垃圾
and burned in Colorado. And the SPAC Yards was actually coming from government surplus auctions. In fact, the very state agency responsible for regulating e-waste was sending its own trash electronics to auction. That is unbelievable. They shared their reporting with news outlets across Colorado. She dug into the story of what happens to old computers. For I News, it's a nonprofit investigative outfit in Denver.
并在科罗拉多州焚烧。而垃圾场实际上来自于政府剩余物资拍卖。事实上，负责监管电子垃圾的州级机构自己就在将废旧电子电器送去拍卖。这太难以置信了。他们与科罗拉多州各地的新闻媒体分享了他们的报道。她深入挖掘了旧电脑最终去向的故事。对于 I News 来说，这是丹佛的一家非营利调查机构。
And she found it. Some of the government's trash computers wind up being shipped to developing nations, sent to the local dump, and even dismantled here in people's backyards and garages. The response was even greater than if the story had been published in just one newspaper. Because of the way we were approaching this in a collaborative way, instead of a competitive way, the story of Colorado's e-waste went from being a story that no media had the capacity to cover to a story that every major news outlet could share with their audience. It was in every daily paper. It was on television. It
她发现了。政府的一些废旧电脑最终被运往发展中国家、送往当地垃圾场，甚至在这里人们的后院和车库里被拆解。其反响甚至比这个故事只在一家报纸上发表时还要大。因为我们以合作而非竞争的方式来处理这个问题，科罗拉多州电子垃圾的故事从一个没有任何媒体有能力报道的故事，变成了一个每个主要新闻 outlet 都可以与他们的受众分享的故事。它登上了每一份日报。它上了电视。它
was on the radio. So suddenly we had this statewide conversation about what was actually happening to Colorado's e-waste. And that had never happened before. And the state legislature then moved to close some of the loopholes that were allowing this to happen. So that's the way the Fourth Estate in a democracy is supposed to work. This is clearly a success story.
上了广播。所以突然之间，我们关于科罗拉多州电子垃圾实际去向的全州范围内的对话开始了。而这以前从未发生过。随后，州立法机关采取行动，堵住了允许这种情况发生的一些漏洞。这就是民主社会中第四权力应该发挥作用的方式。这显然是一个成功的故事。
Laura lost her job at the Rocky, but that led her to set up I News. She got stories like the e-waste investigation out to the public. The government made changes to the program in response. But Laura still thinks there is an immense cost when a newspaper closes. It took two years for us to get the story out. So how many children were exposed and wound up with high levels of lead in their blood
劳拉在《洛矶山新闻》失去了工作，但这促使她创立了 I News。她将诸如电子垃圾调查这样的故事公之于众。政府作为回应改变了该计划。但劳拉仍然认为，当一家报纸倒闭时，代价是巨大的。我们花了两年时间才把这个故事报道出来。那么有多少儿童在暴露于环境中并在血液中含有高水平的铅
while we were trying to figure out a way to get the story out? Yes, I think when there's a really important story that a journalist somehow finds out about, it will eventually get out, but my God, who was harmed while we waited. And those are only the stories we know are going untold. It's the unknown, unknown that is also very worrisome to me. One of the bedrock assumptions of economics is that when individuals behave rationally, good things happen to them. Good things happen to their communities, their society. The invisible hand of the market takes all of our rational selfish decisions and produces a society that flourishes. Much of the time, this does
在我们试图找出将故事公之于众的方法的同时？是的，我认为当发生了一件记者以某种方式发现的真正重要的故事时，它最终会公之于众，但天哪，在我们等待的时候，谁受到了伤害。而这些还只是我们知道没有被报道出来的故事。未知之未知也让我非常担忧。经济学的基本假设之一是，当个人理性行事时，好事就会发生。好事会降临到他们的社区、他们的社会。市场的无形手汇聚了我们所有理性自私的决定，并造就了一个繁荣的社会。大多数时候，这确实
work. But it turns out that for things like police departments, public schools, and newspapers, the logic of the market doesn't produce the outcomes we want to see. We can all end up paying more when we all try individually to pay less. Many experts have tried to think of ways communities can solve problems that market forces don't solve on their own. How do you get people to pitch in even when it's in their rational self-interest, to free-ride off of others?
奏效。但事实证明，对于警察局、公立学校和报纸之类的事情来说，市场的逻辑并没有产生我们希望看到的结果。当我们都试图在个人层面上少付钱时，我们最终可能会支付更多。许多专家一直在思考社区如何解决市场力量无法自行解决的问题。你如何让人门即使在符合其理性自身利益的情况下也去捐款，去搭别人的便车？
These solutions begin with the same insight. Sometimes, when you try and pinch pennies, you end up paying in pounds. This episode was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Path Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Correll, Kat Schuchnacht, and Lu Sheikwaba. Special thanks to producer Meredith Turk for getting us the voices of the Denver residents you heard at the top of the show and to Andy Huthur for his engineering help.
这些解决方案始于相同的洞察。有时，当你试图省小钱时，最终付出的代价会更大。本集由雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕斯·沙、托马斯·刘、劳拉·科雷尔、卡特·舒赫纳赫特和鲁·谢伊瓦巴。特别感谢制作人梅雷迪思·特克为我们争取到了你在节目开头听到的丹佛居民的声音，以及安迪·胡瑟提供的工程帮助。
Hidden Brain has a request for you. We'd like to better understand who's listening and how you're using podcasts. Please help us out by completing a short, anonymous survey at npr.org slash podcast survey. It takes less than 10 minutes and really helps support the show. That's npr.org slash podcast survey. A Ran Sanghiro this week is a mentor of mine, Arlene Morgan. Arlene was an editor and recruiter at the Philadelphia Inquara, who took a chance on me some 25 years ago.
《Hidden Brain》有一个请求。我们希望更好地了解谁在听以及你如何使用播客。请花不到10分钟的时间在 npr.org/podcast survey 上完成一份简短的匿名调查，这真的对支持节目很有帮助。那是 npr.org/podcast survey。这周的“Ran Sanghiro”是我的导师阿琳·摩根。阿琳是《费城问询报》的编辑和招聘人员，大约25年前她给了我一个机会。
She believed in great journalism and she also believed that in order to get great journalism, you need to invest in recruiting, training and developing a diverse pool of journalists. I owe the start of my career as a newspaper journalist to her. That work forms the foundation of what I do today at Hidden Brain. Thanks Arlene. You can find more Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this show, please tell one friend about it. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她相信伟大的新闻业，她还相信，为了获得伟大的新闻业，你需要投资于招聘、培训和发展多元化的记者群体。我作为一名报纸记者的职业生涯起步要归功于她。这项工作构成了我今天在《Hidden Brain》所做工作的基础。谢谢阿琳。你可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上找到更多《Hidden Brain》的内容。如果你喜欢这个节目，请告诉一位朋友。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是 NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。